barrett-jackson auto auction is
happening now at the las vegas
convention center and earlier
i got a peek at the incredible rides
including one well-known car from our
childhood
zoinks well that wasn't too bad look at
this guys it's the mystery machine just
one of the many vehicles
that you can bid on here at barrett
jackson and this is brian miner
he's with ford country brian i didn't
realize that the mystery machine
is a ford this one is in fact you know
there's several different models but
this one is definitely a ford
you know i walk by this and i just think
about how many afternoons i spent
watching this cartoon yeah watching
scooby doo
everything everything here is part of
somebody's life right yeah really every
cor every car
tells a story and and what's this one
here this is a 59 ranchero you know this
was more considered the gentleman's
truck
the the truck to do what he needs to do
on the weekend but also still go out on
the town in
that's a that's a nice piece of
machinery right there right spinning
around to your left lance we have a
we have an all-american muscle car the
camaro ss camaro ss
great car not as nice as my mustang but
it is a cool car
oh yeah okay okay you know hi so okay
you know i got to stay true to the brand
a little bit can you get a shot of the
tires in the back lands look at the big
tires there in the back and the little
ones in the front why do they do that on
a muscle car
a lot of times so you wanted the smaller
tire for more steering and capability
and the rears tires for more traction so
that it grips and goes
um and and the thinner tire in the front
really helped the car track a little bit
better
barrett-jackson has something for
everyone and you can buy tickets and
come check it out
and and this year it looks like a work
truck to me kind of restored and
modified though yeah lately to the next
generations come in and taken all these
old trucks and just really modified them
putting modern motors in them
but just really love the history and and
the look of these
older cars these were more used for like
tow trucks now you guys
you've come down here you've been on
cars as well so what do you look i got
about 30 seconds here do you look at the
engine you look at the history of the
car what do you look at
we look at the bones you know really we
want the bones is where everything works
it's
you know we can work on engines but we
want a solid frame a solid body
something that's clean and smooth
barrett-jackson it's happening all
weekend come down here and check it out
look at this cobra right here
all right barrett-jackson i'm sitting
there watching i'm so enthralled
barrett-jackson auto auction is in town
until sunday
and coming up in the 4 o'clock hour i
will show you some cars that are
connected
to famous stars